The joe rogan experience. That's
what they're going to do. Yup.
Maybe they'll do that
international fight week to don.
Don Sizzler,
trying to get these ratings
up for Fox buys. Ww.
Imagine if Brock's first fight back
as John Jones. Yeah, I can. Yeah,
I can just the car. Don't look in that
mother fucker. It's not July. Yes.
Yes. Steep a DC Granshawn Jones. Brock.
Preach. Tyron Woodley.
Dosign Joe's or Tayga?
Max Holloway. Amanda Nunez. Cyborg.
We busted this load on this one card.
Whew. Whew. Whew, whew. We can
still do the ratings did that,
that place would be the
same. It'd be insane.
That'd be one of the greatest
cards of all talkers.
And then I taught you sprinkle
in this swink a little cm punk.
Mm. You wouldn't be able
to do that one. Why?
Because that one needs so much money.
The one that I'm thinking about,
which one? You know the
one, which one? Joe?
The one that was a lot of sprinkles on
top. Which will you know that boxer guy?
What's his name? Oh, you
talking about employee Tim?
Something money that we keep
talking about. If that happened,
and this is by the way, I believe
you and I were the first speculate.
That's publicly correct.
I think that's the fight.
I think that's the fight to make. I
agree. I don't know if it'll ever happen,
but I think it does. It does happen.
It happens on its own individual card.
You put a kick ass card underneath it,
but I don't know if you put like a UFC
200 size kick ass card or anything. No.
Cause Floyd and cm punk skin cell
is a cell. And also if you're Floyd,
just leave it from Floyd's perspective.
All right, pay me this much money,
which I boatload of cash and also give
me the guy who has zero experience like
me and cm punk comes a huge
name so it makes sense.
It's the only fight to make for Floyd
cause condo literally kill them. Yeah,
you can't do that because it
wouldn't be fair. It's not fair.
It's not beat up Floyd and
cm punk in the same night.
People would understand the difference
between Connor Boxing Floyd,
which you've got clearly outclassed,
but he hit him like Floyd is.
I can do anything. No, it's
no competition. It doesn't.
It's going to be awful.
It doesn't make sense. Make sense? He'll
get kicked once in the legs and be like,
oh my God, now I can't walk and then he
gets kicked in the same spot. I'm like,
oh Jesus Christ and his folding over and
he's getting front kicked in the gut.
Connor's talking shit to him.
That head kick the viciously and then
you're on that highlight reel and the UFC
is using that over loop over and
over and it takes one clinch.
Just one clinch and
you're on on your back.
If you're seeing punk than her fighting
Floyd, I'm army crawling over Floyd.
You're not even, I go ahead and
punch me. But Dan Karate style,
you stand karate style and you throw
sidekicks and you just walk towards him
throwing sidekicks. There's so
many gifts to the cage. Yes.
Why would you even want to box them?
You stand total Wonderboy side stance.
Just stand like this way back. Liotta
Machida style and just throw sidekicks,
keep them off you. And then when
the move is, whenever it happens,
get that client shotty,
la, fucking everything.
The guy weighs a 145 legitimate pounds.
That's what Floyd was even just bear
hug them and just pull them on top of me
and sweep and we get full amount. I would
literally just come at Floyd like this.
Just walked straight forward like
the terminator two. Wait. Yeah.
He could make welterweight unboxing.
He could.
That's the only problem with this fight
that were spiked lane is 20 pounds.
What weight are they going to fight that
because see a punks nuts. Small. No, he,
he was uh,
a legit sized one 70.
So he would go and catch weight here.
You don't have to be catch weight 60.
See that's the other thing. You Drain cm
punk down to one 60 and he's Foxville.
Yeah, let's do that. Yeah.
Well, well, here's the thing.
At one 70 he doesn't have a lot of muscle,
but he's got a little bit of fat so maybe
he might be able to do 65 he does it
smart and long, you know, he takes a
long time to do it. Adjust as calories,
really ramps up as cardio.
Just forces himself to do an hour of
cardio after every training session.
Has anyone seen him lately?
A man looking thinner? No.
Just Kinda have to look a lot funner
to get that fight. Or Floyd just says,
I don't give a fuck. I'm going to like
this dude up. Cause when they're standing,
when?
When he's got to close the distance on cm,
Floyd has four ounce gloves on.
Are you fucking kidding me?
And he's impossible to hit. He's
in Pi. You're not going to hit him.
That's not happened to catch coming in
and it's gonna beat fucking at night
night. Even the leg kicks like,
boy, can you even kick his legs?
How fast the CM punk kick.
You know what I mean?
We're not talking about like yachts and
Clyde. That's not the move for cm punk,
sir. Just do what you gotta do to get to
the ground. We have a karate background.
Cm punk. Yes. Much as
a, I have a crowded bar
and I'm not making fun of him.
When he was like 13 or some shit,
I guess doesn't count.
I play dodge ball to when the [inaudible]
not on my resume, doesn't count.
Soccer player. I'm going to put
that on my fucking soccer player.
My Twitter handle now. I played soccer.
Yeah. That doesn't count, man. Play it.
Yeah. We were so heartbroken.
You're right. Yeah. Jesus.
I don't want to throw it. It's that cold
brew. This new Cobra was snacking on.
Yeah.